work I do is is a combination of
economics information security and
psychology we did find surprising
results when we started applying
economics and behavioral psychology to
understanding in particular privacy
decision-making when you provide
assurances about the privacy being
protected to individuals individuals
become actually less willing to provide
personal information which is a counter
it into user and the reason we believe
is because for these phenomena is that
people become primed to think about
privacy another study which was somewhat
surprising which we just completed
recently related to how you can combine
different sets of data and each set
alone seems rather innocent or in
opposed in the sense that it's not
particularly damaging or sensitive but
by combining this data you can end up
with something which is more than the
sum or the original data specifically we
show that we can aggregate data coming
from different sources such as online
social networks and other public data
provided by the government and we can
down end up predicting individuals
social security numbers and this is an
important lesson because it shows how
the challenges that we have as human
beings in dealing with our personal
privacy in a complex information society
because information regulation is
ubiquitous and is silent it happens
everywhere because of all the computers
and electronic gadgets that we carry
around or which are monitoring pretty
much every every hour or our personal
and professional life in silent because
we often don't actually even realize
that this information dissemination is
going on and this creates lots of
troubles in our decision making because
when we don't realize information we are
revealing in this information this trace
of data are pretty much continuous
in a way we're almost not equipped to
act in a efficient optimal way and
decide what should we protect the show
and what should Olivia so hence the
importance of the kind of research we we
try to do combine economics psychology
to really understand what people know
why they act the way they do and whether
we can try to find the solutions
you